la realmente con estas estimaciones
224 curules es un resultado
decepcionante no obtiene la mayor
reacción absoluta eso era la hipótesis
más probable pero incluso obtendría un
resultado de curules aún más bajo que
una mayoría relativa que se esperaba por
lo tanto vamos a tener un parlamento
morse lado
esparcido en diferentes coaliciones y
para poder hacer pasar algunos proyectos
de ley se va a necesitar necesariamente
hacer alianzas incluso la oposición
liderada por roly - y la coalición de la
nube se va a tener un gran margen de
maniobra para obstruir o obstruir ser
los proyectos de ley de la mayoría
presidencial bueno y hablemos de la
coalición de izquierda los nubes que
está conformada por cuatro partidos la
francia y sumisa líder allianz lumen
lanzó los comunistas los socialistas y
el partido de los verdes en la primera
vuelta en francia y dos vueltas
legislativas en la primera vuelta se
estimaba que ellos podrían sacar más de
200 curules más de 200 escaños en la
asamblea y ahora vemos que podría sacar
un poco menos y no están tan cabeza a
cabeza con la coalición juntos de mayo
esto quiere decir que no les fue tan
bien como se esperaba o de todas maneras
es un resultado histórico para la
izquierda francesa
no creo que sea un tan buen resultado
para la izquierda en realidad hay que
ver el tiempo largo si miramos por
ejemplo los resultados de hace cinco
años también la izquierda estaba
debilitada pero sin unión ahora en 2022
hubo una unión de la izquierda pero si
lo miramos de cara a los resultados
anteriores
2002 y más adelante la izquierda sacaba
entre 40 y 35 por ciento de los votos en
la segunda vuelta por lo tanto la
izquierda perdió relativamente fuerzas
en términos de porcentaje de voto